even the stars who come
on our show get star struck here's
someone we love
talking about a time they met someone
they love
i did a movie called what planet are you
from
and i showed up and annette benny was on
the set
and they set a chair up for me next to
her
and she started talking to me like i was
a normal person
and i and she misread me because i
wasn't normal i
i could not get over how star struck i
was
she was actually very nice about it she
engaged me in conversation
and i was trying to act really cool and
i literally slid down the chair i almost
fell off the chair trying to act cool
because i lost my spine i lost all the
awareness of my spine
so anyway if annette benning is out
there i blew it i wish i could have
talked to you like a normal person and
maybe we'll do it again someday
the biggest time i was starstruck i was
invited to an after party
at the russian tea room to meet paul
mccartney talking to paul mccartney is
just bizarre because
you know he'll be like you know joan
used to sit you know like that and you
go
john lennon that's who you talking about
like yeah cause you're paul mccartney
and yeah and so i just kept like kind of
stuttering just staring and kind of
blinking a lot i was asking all the dumb
questions you asked about the beatles
and paul mccartney
i remember i told my mom i might be
going to this my mom's like if you go to
the
russian tea room you have to get a
moscow mule
owner comes out can i get you anything i
go can i have a
moscow mule thinking paul would be like
he's cool
do you want to re-foam the beatles with
you in it he doesn't even hear me and uh
the rest is uh history and we currently
don't speak
the first time i was completely star
struck
was when i met janet jackson the first
time i met her
was in miami at club bed she was dating
germain dupree at the time and i was i
was
at the club with wilmer valderrama
all of a sudden wilmer comes running up
to me and he's like yo jd
wants you to meet janet jackson and i
immediately start crying
and i hop up there and she pops up like
she gets up and she says
i'm so proud of you and i
when i say ugly cry with like snot the
whole thing
for janet jackson even know who the heck
i was much less to be
saying it to my face as she hugged me
was
the dream like the dream i loved her
that day and i loved her i love i
continued to love her i have been
absolutely star struck two times
one was seeing britney spears's backup
dancer
it was the most important day of my life
his name is tj
i'm sure you guys know who he is he is
iconic
and i saw him at a restaurant in santa
monica and i almost cried
and the second time i was starstruck was
seeing tori spelling aka
donna martin at a charity event in
brentwood when i was 10.
i was getting into an elevator after
finishing an audition
and as i walk into the elevator there's
a man just kind of sitting
standing there and sitting standing and
um i'm looking at him going like why do
i why do i know this face why do i know
his face
and it's uh it was henry winkler
and i just continued to stare at him
until finally he was like
do we know each other i was like i don't
know do we i probably have to say shonda
rhimes i think when i went from my
audition and that's from the rhymes it
it kind of put me off there i was like
this is a big deal but um
yeah shonda rhymes and then i have
another story but it's kind of
disappointing and um i went to a party
back when we could
go to parties last year and um
and i was you know it was getting late
and i said to johnny who plays anthony
in the show i said i'm gonna leave i'm
quite tired
and he calls me five minutes later and
he says
rihanna's here rihanna's here you miss
rihanna
so i was gutted i missed out on meeting
rihanna but um
i would have been very startled had i
met her
i'm very stuck on what story to tell
because i've been star struck
literally so many times but i think one
time that comes to my mind is the first
time i ever met lori hernandez a member
of the 2016
final five rio de janeiro olympic
women's gymnastics teams from the united
states of america honey
it was like an invisible person smacked
me across the face and i did like three
shenay turns ran into a wall and almost
started to hyperventilate and cry
and then i looked up and i realized that
like her mom was standing in front of me
watching me like have a nervous
breakdown in front of her daughter and i
was like oh my gosh
i'm just a super fan i'm so obsessed
love so much
so that's so that's i feel like that was
like the biggest reaction i ever made to
like seeing someone and
not being able to keep my cool
whatsoever boy moment i was star struck
um 1997.
i'm in new york city and i've got a
meeting with paul newman
my cab dropped me off about 20 blocks
short of paul newman and it was in the
winter so
i love to be on time i didn't want to be
late for the paul newman meeting
but i had five minutes to cover 20
blocks so i ran
i remember it was freezing cold but i
still broke a sweat to get there i got
there
and uh met one of my favorite actors
something that i looked up to someone
who i looked up to about who they were
as actors on the screen and who they the
life they lived off the screen
uh we played a little pool uh we chatted
this and that for a little over an hour
and
as i left i'll never forget the last
words he said to me i was walking out
the door of his office about to shut up
behind me
and he goes hey mcconaughey i turned
around and said yes sir he goes
give him hell that was pretty cool
that was such a fun story
[Music]
you